all right let's go back to Discord and
hear from more people you can find the
David Pacman show Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord let's go to the node from India
V node from India welcome to the David
Pacman show
hello David can you hear me yes I can
how are you I'm doing well thank you
okay so uh I wanted to ask about uh you
know the recent State visit by uh prime
minister of India Narendra Modi to the
US Joe Biden invited him
um the interesting thing that I noticed
is just uh some of the
members of Congress by Godless uh
addressed to Congress right yes
so one of them was a congresswoman
ilanovar I guess
so my question is uh she she met with
like
um the thing is she told that uh you
know the the Muslims
are discriminated in India and uh you
know their rights are not respected and
such reasons so she boycotted it but my
question is she went to you know turkey
and met with Aragon and uh she went to
Pakistan and met with Imran Khan and
other such people
I mean those people are not exactly
known for you know respecting uh human
rights and religious freedom right yeah
so
this is the hypocrisy that uh I'm seeing
from some Progressive members of
Congress well I want to hear your
thoughts on it yeah so listen I'm going
to take your word for it on what ilhan
Omar said about anti-muslim
discrimination in India let's assume
you're accurately representing it I'm
unaware of what she said uh I think that
this is it would not be unique to ilhan
Omar
um to play a little soft with some of
the authoritarian leaning folks that
you're talking about including erdogan
and turkey while levying criticisms in
similar
um circumstances about other leaders
this wouldn't be unique to ilhan Omar
there are there is a contingent of the
left that does this sort of thing
somehow they end up always going soft on
you know whether it's erdogan or Putin
or Maduro or Castro or whatever the case
may be it's not it's not new I don't
have anything in particular to add about
it often it's rooted in wanting to apply
not wanting to it often applies a
different standard to the United States
and allies versus other countries and I
I don't know that I have too much more
to say about I know that there are
people in my audience who every time I
mention the name ilhan Omar want me
canceled but to be totally fair vinod I
didn't hear her make the comments that
you're talking about but the double
standard you're bringing up does not
come as a shock to me
yeah I mean uh hearing from you know the
discourse in the U.S it seems like you
know if someone is not knowledgeable in
of uh India and what's going on here
someone who hears the rhetoric that uh
these people you know espoused uh they
think that uh some sort of genocide is
going on like some sort of Muslim
genocide is going on here which is
ridiculous you know I mean uh I'm not
pro BJP or Pro Modi or anything I mean
uh it's fine to criticize him that's
okay but you know uh I see the parallel
here because Elan Omar you know
sometimes crisis is Israel also so uh
you know sometimes it is uh I feel like
it is anti-Semitic so I think it is uh I
can see the parallel between here and
there well listen let weeks we should
really take these all individually I do
think there is evidence of anti-muslim
discrimination in India it would be
wrong of me to characterize it exactly
because it's it's something I've read
about a little bit and there are a
number of different studies there's a
Reuters report NBC News has written
about it about concerns about Muslim
rights in India I think it's perfectly
fair and correct to have a concern about
that you seem to be going more to the
hypocrisy or double standard and I think
that's fair
yeah yeah I agree with you thanks David
thanks for thank you there is V node
from India great to hear from you why
don't we go next to uh how about Bobby
from Southern California Bobby from
Southern California welcome to the show
hey David how are you doing well
good uh so I have a question for you how
do we get back to talking about policies
and things that matter to Americans such
as Affordable Health Care education and
housing how do we shift Focus towards
these major issues instead of
manufactured issues related to you know
Caravan CRT lgbtq plus Asylum Seekers
indoctrination Etc
my take is that it just feels like
moderates and right Wingers are focusing
on the wrong problems that don't
actually impact them on a day-to-day
basis or create better outcomes for
their own livelihoods my perception is
that Americans are willing to fight the
wrong battles focus on the wrong
priorities and continue to vote for
politicians who often vote against their
best interest because they get grifted
to fight ideological battles
two possible answers there's two paths
Bobby
and we've talked about this before the
question is
how can the left Force policy back into
the national discussion as the primary
issue despite the right's insistence on
ignoring policy doing culture War issues
and that sort of thing two answers okay
one answer is the left needs to stop
engaging on every single one of these
cultural issues and uh just talk about
policy only and eventually the people of
the country will realize wow that's
quite a contrast they will stop paying
attention to the cultural War issues and
they will pay attention to the policy
discussions of the left sounds a little
pie in the sky okay on the other side
there's the argument the left actually
just needs to defeat the right on all of
these culture issues instead of sort of
playing a little Coy with the culture
issues and saying these are contrived
and overblown
uh make the landscape one where you
actually fight the right on those issues
and then once we beat the right on those
issues then we can go back to policy I
think the problem is the more engagement
the right gets on these issues the more
they will push and it's not actually
going to be so simple to say we've done
away with the culture stuff now we can
get back to policy I actually think uh
that um our guest earlier this week Joe
Berkowitz made maybe the best point on
this the way to do it is
expose how stupid these culture issues
are and in the same breath in the same
conversations get back to those
important policy issues I don't believe
it's a perfect solution I believe that
to some degree the right is going to I
mean the culture issues they get
headlines they sound interesting they
sound titillating in different ways but
I like that idea which is to say hey
guys listen every time you want to talk
about this this school stuff you just
lie these things aren't going on it's a
waste of time there's no cat litter
boxes for students who identify as cats
Librarians and teachers know what books
kids should read okay now let's get back
to figuring out how to make food more
affordable and Healthcare more
accessible I think that some kind of
in-between approach is probably the best
and do you believe that since 2016 when
Trump was elected that Americans are
more leaning towards listening to the
other side of the aisle or do we still
have a lot of work to get there a lot of
work to get there a lot of work to get
there yeah thank you
Bobby from SoCal thank you for the call
thank you all right kind of a sad
reality but it is what it is you know